zum heutigen thema heute wollen wir uns
mit immanuel kants theorie
auseinandersetzen und dann zu hegels
wahrheit' theorie übergehen hegel ist
vielleicht der interessanteste der
spannendste wahrheit denker die es gibt
sind wir alle spannend wollen wir doch
übergehen
ich habe ihn auch noch ich weiß nicht ob
sie alle bekommen haben ich habe ihn
auch noch in ein paar gedanken geschickt
gedanken bezüglich meiner auffassung wie
man sich seminararbeiten schreiben
sollte haben sie alle die es eh themen
bekommen von mir mögliche themen ja ich
habe dann eine spezifische art und weise
der essayist zu verstehen oder die art
und weise wie man sie schreibt ich bin
der meinung befassen sie sich intensiv
mit dem originaltext gehen sie nicht
gleich auf sekundärliteratur über das
ist eine gefahr weil sie dann nämlich
nicht mehr originell sind unser
philosophie kommt es darauf an dass sie
in eigenen zugang eigene gedanken
entwickeln wenn sie gleich auf die
sekundärliteratur übergehen wird ihnen
alles denken abgenommen und im
schlimmsten fall plagiieren sie am ende
bewusst oder unbewusst weil sie einfach
kompensieren wollen verdunkeln wollen
dass sie nicht selbst leisten
das ist eine große gefahr deswegen und
das lernen wir ja auch hier in diesem
seminar immer mit gewissen sachfragen
mitleid fragen an texte herangehen die
texte zu befragen wenn sie an den text
eine interessante frage formulieren dann
antwortet der ihnen wie ein
naturwissenschaftliches experiment in
dem die natur auf ihre frage antwortet
und sie eine interessante linie
herausbekommen all das möchte ich ihnen
ans herz legen selbst sich gedanken
machen sich frühzeitig mit den
originaltexten auseinanderzusetzen und
nicht alles aus zweiter hand zu beziehen
sie werden einfach dann nicht
eigenständige zugänge entwickeln können
das ist in der philosophie ganz wichtig
und deswegen lesen wie hier auch immer
den originaltext ich habe ihn zwei
sekundärliteratur text empfohlen einmal
von bertrand russell
das ist ein sehr sehr guter kurzer text
den sie im sap system finden
der sich mit den problemen und den
vorzügen von korrespondenz und kohärenz
theorie befasst das sind ja unsere zwei
haupt theorien und dann habe ich noch
dieses diesem sammelband von markus
enders und anderen herausgeben empfohlen
wo sie zur gesamten geschichte der
philosophie aufsätze finden über den
begriff der wahrheit
das ist also so meine meine vorrede
sozusagen zur heutigen sitzung und wenn
sie fragen haben können sie jederzeit
mini e mails schreiben oder wenn sie
fragen haben zu irgendwelchen möglichen
se themen können sie das gerne mit mir
auch in einer sprechstunde mal klären
oder sie schreiben mir einfach eine
e-mail
ja dann geht es jetzt zum eigentlichen
inhalt der heutigen sitzung heute wollen
wir erst noch mal wir uns mit immanuel
kant beschäftigen
und wir haben da wir übrigen üblich
leitfragen und zwar lauten wie folgt die
erste frage ist inwiefern vertritt kant
eine korrespondenz theorie der wahrheit
das ist unsere erste frage die zweite
frage lassen sich beim auch ansätze
einer kohärenz theorie entdecken
dritte frage welche rolle spielt die
subjektive erkenntnis in seiner
wahrheit' theorie
wir haben ja gesehen dass seite card das
objekt ein ganz wichtige rolle hat das
objekt muss versuchen über bestimmte
methoden über bestimmte vorrichtungen
zur wahrheit zu gelangen
die wahrheit ist nicht mehr frei haus
verfügbar sondern die wahrheit die
bedarf verschiedene richtungen
und dann ist die wahrheit ist hier oder
objekt die welt wie sie wirklich ist und
das ist die frage wie hier dieser bezüge
hergestellt werden kann und der bezug
der wird plötzlich problematisch in
diesem mittelalterlichen kontext hatten
wir so eine einheit der waren zu bieten
obliegt immer schon aufeinander
verwiesen für das selbst vom objekt hier
ein bezug hergestellt wurde zum subjekt
bei der augustinus hat mir die bekannte
stelle das augustinus sagt das täuscht
uns das 10 gibt vor silber zu sein
das ist aber kein echtes silber sein
falsches silber das silber wird das 10
täuscht uns darin dass es uns so
vorkommt oder uns auf die idee bringt
das ist ja sein könnte würden wir heute
nie sagen heute wird nur sagen wir
irgend uns in unserem bezug zum objekt
und nicht das objekt täuscht uns ja das
ist interessant und diese dieser diese
gegen bezug wurde aufgehoben
dieser rahmen dieses setting wurde
verändert und hat sehr kritisch so wie
im objekt im verhältnis gesehen mitte
kartmann hat gesagt das objekt ist
dunkel oder wir selbst so ist es
vielleicht besser wir selbst sind gar
nicht so verfasst dass wir uns auf das
objekt beziehen können wir sollten bevor
wir uns auf das optik in der welt
beziehen sollten wir uns erstmal auf uns
selbst beziehen und fragen wie müssen
wir verfasst sein unser erkenntnis
apparat damit er überhaupt offen ist für
das was in der welt als war erkannt
werden kann
das ist das entscheidend also nicht
gleich zum objekt zu den dingen sind
erst mal fragen wie kann ich da
überhaupt hier kommen was muss ich bei
mir voraussetzen dass es so was ist
wahrheit kennen wahrheit' erkenntnis
fähig seien jetzt mal ist und in dieser
tradition steht auch kant und hegel den
wieder in der zweiten sitzung vielleicht
noch per hand
in der zweiten hälfte noch behandeln
können der wird sagen dieses gesamte
setting von descartes aber auch bei kant
ist falsch das gesamte setting dass man
erst sich selbst prüfen muss wo man zur
wahrheit kommt das ist sehr cool er ein
grund ist eben der wie kann ich denn
erkennen dass ich richtig erkennen kann
aber nicht sagt wahrheit setzt voraus
die erkenntnis der eigentlichen
subjektivität eigentlichen erkenntnis
leistung dann kann ich mich fragen auf
welcher basis kann ich meine eigene
kenntnis leistung erkennen und wiederum
das erkennen und so weiter und so fort
wir hätten hier lauter solche solche
reflexion stufen und erkennt da hier ein
ende
das problem das ist hegel die wird das
kant unter anderem vorwerfen aber jetzt
gehen wir erstmal auf kant ein
und genau das angebot muss objektivität
heißen also wie fern kein objektivität
also hier wahrheit objektivität durch
subjektivität geleistet werden das ist
auch noch ein punkt bei kant kann zeigt
erstens mal müssen unser subjektivität
prüfen bevor wir zur objektivität kommen
können und zweitens liegt objektivität
nicht einfach nur so vor in der welt
wieder irgendwie so ein tisch in der
welt steht und ich muss sie nur noch
erkennen sind kann sagt ging den wir den
tisch erkennen konstituieren wir ihnen
also wir selbst das subjekt ist an der
wahrheit oder an der objektivität des
tisches beteiligt das klingt jetzt
erstmal sehr abstrus ne aber bekannt hat
er gute gründe dafür zu sagen bestimmte
strukturen der objekte in der welt zb
ihre objektivität überhaupt ihre
substantially tät die haben die dinge
nicht an sich das ding an sich sondern
die haben sie durch uns durch unsere
erkenntnis mechanismen genau das können
heute noch ein bisschen klären das führt
auch zu weit uns geht es jetzt vor allem
darum wie kann seine zwei theorien
von korrespondenz theorie und
kunsttheorie zusammenbringt das
interessiert uns jetzt vor allem genau
dann käme eigentlich mal loslegen ich
weiß nicht haben sie ihm eine
zusammenfassung gelesen auf die seminar
schauen sie da mal vorbei und auch die
folien der heutigen sitzung finden sie
auf die seminar können sich
herunterladen
weil wir haben wir doch bei hegel jetzt
in der zweiten hälfte dieses seminares
recht viele texte und da habe ich
nochmal eine zusätzliche auswahl
getroffen
also wir lesen jetzt mal ganz kürzung
aus die kritik der reinen vernunft aus
der b- auflage die auflage die erste
auflage ist 1781 erschienen und wir
lesen also aus der zweiten auflage
ich lese noch mal vor dass es ganz
bekanntes zitat die alte und berühmte
frage womit man die logica in die enge
zu treiben vermeinte und sie dahin zu
bringen suchte dass sie sich entweder
auf einer elenden die allele mussten
betreffen lassen oder ihre unwissenheit
mithin die eitelkeit ihrer ganzen kunst
bekennen sollten ist diese was ist
wahrheit
die namen erklärung der wahrheit dass
sie nämlich die übereinstimmung der
erkenntnis mit ihrem gegenstand der sei
mithin geschenkt und vorausgesetzt man
verlangt aber zu wissen welches das
allgemeine unsichere kriterium der
wahrheit einer jeden erkenntnis sei also
definition ist klar das objekt muss mit
seinem gegenstand und da einstimmen
korrespondenz theorie aber wie kann ich
erkennen ob es tatsächlich mit dem
gegenstand übereinstimmen das ist die
frage was das sichere kritik daran kann
ich erkennen dass meine erkenntnis
überhaupt bekenntnis ist woran kann ich
erkennen dass ich mich in der wahrheit
befinde
das wäre so eine kritik an der
mittelalterlichen definition
mittelalterliches ist sehnen sich an
anselm von canterbury
der hat eigentlich nur solche
definitionen von korrespondenz gegeben
im ausgang von aristoteles weiter card
fing es an die karte dann ja aber wie
kann ich denn überhaupt sicher sein dass
mein urteilen oder meine subjektivität
wie der wilde einstimmt dafür ist dann
an dass man nach einem sicheren
kriterium der wahrheit gesucht hat ja
und dann geht's weiter
das hatten wir in der letzten sitzung
schon ich lese noch weiter was aber das
erkenntnis der bloßen form nach mit
beiseite setzung alles inhalts betrifft
so ist ebenso klar dass logik sofern sie
die eigenen und not mit dem regen des
verstandes vorträgt eben in diesen
regeln kriterien der wahrheit darlegen
müsse denn was diesen der spricht ist
falsch weil der verstand dabei ist ein
allgemeinen regeln des denkens mithin
sich selbst wieder streitet diese
kriterien aber betreffen nur die form
der wahrheit das heißt des denkens
überhaupt ist insofern ganz richtig aber
nicht hinreichend genutzt gleich eine
erkenntnis die logischen form völlig
gemäss sein möchten das ist sich selbst
nicht der sprecher so kann sie doch noch
immer dem gegenstand widersprechen
also ist das bloß logische kriterium der
wahrheit nämlich die übereinstimmung ein
erkenntnissen mit den allgemeinen
formalen gesetzen des verstandes und der
vernunft zwar die conditio sine qua non
mithin die negative bedingungen aller
wahrheit weiter aber kann die logik
nicht gehen und den irrtum den ich die
form sind den inhalt betrifft kann die
logik durch keinen probierstand denken
was ist jetzt in diesem zitat nochmal
ausgedrückt das ist jetzt die zentrale
einsicht von kant die auch ein bisschen
mitteilt
hmm
sie hat kein bezug zur wirklichkeit die
bloße logische verstandes mexiko heavens
es könnte auch andere corrente der logik
nicht widersprechen diese theorien geben
die aber falsch sind oder es könnte
mehrere geben und die sich eigentlich
ausschließen oder b und nur eines kann
richtig sein
a und b sind aber vielleicht sogar sich
widersprechen oder konträr muss endlich
kontradiktorischen sind konträr
zueinander jedenfalls sagen sich nicht
nicht dasselbe aus sind aber beide
logisch den verstand nicht gesprächen
fragen wir uns was ist jetzt her die
ware theorie wenn doch beide logisch
widerspruchsfrei sind ja ja
genau also es kann keine wahrheit war
keine keine theorie geben die wir warnen
können wenn sie logische widersprüche
enthält das geht nicht
also es ist so damit eben eine einsatz
oder eine theorie war ist muss sie
logisch widerspruchsfrei sein sie muss
im logischen raum existieren können oder
auch sie muss in allen möglichen welten
allen möglichen welten die uns denken
können muss sie möglich sein aber dazu
kommt noch dass es denn die hinreichende
bedingung sie muss eben auch noch ein
inhalt haben
inhaltlich muss sie auch noch einen
bezug herstellen
zur objektivität das ist also das
entscheidende kann zeigt hier wie gesagt
wir brauchen zu einem moment der
kohärenz theorie aber das genügt allein
nicht wir brauchen auch noch ein ganz
starkes man mit der korrespondenz und
jetzt stellen wir uns natürlich die
frage wie genau müssen wir uns die
korrespondenz denken das ist ja das
eigentliche spannte wie findet der bezug
von subjekt und objekt statt weiter geht
es die allgemeine logik löst nun das
ganze formale geschäft des verstandes
und der vernunft ins seine elemente auf
und stellt sie als prinzipien alle
logischen beurteilen und zur erkenntnis
da dieser teil der logik kann daher
analytik heißen
das ist praktisch dieses auflösen löst
auf das ist griechisch analysis heißt
einfach nur auflösung dieser teil der
logik kann daher nötig kaisern ist eben
darum der wenigstens negative pro
birstein der wahrheit in dem man
zuvörderst alle erkenntnis ihrer form
nach an diesen regeln prüfen und
schätzen muss jemand sie selbst ihrem
inhalt nach untersucht um auszumachen ob
sie in ansehung des gegenstandes
positive wahrheit enthalten
weil aber die bloße form des
erkenntnisses so sehr sie auch mit
logischen gesetzen übereinstimmen mag
noch lange nicht ausreicht materielle
objektive wahrheit dem erkenntnisse
darum auszumachen
so kann sich niemand bloß mit der logik
wagen über gegenstände zu urteilen
und irgendetwas zu behaupten ohne von
ihnen vorher gegründete erkundigung
außer der logik angezogen zu haben um
hernach bloß die benutzung und die
verknüpfung derselben in einem
zusammenhängenden ganzen nach logischen
gesetzen zu versuchen noch besser aber
sie lediglich danach zu prüfen also hier
noch mal eine andere weise ausgedrückt
es ist nur der negative probierstand die
logik kann man sich das noch mal mit
anderen worten vorstellen liefern ist
die logik der negative birstein der
wahrheit
genau dann brauche ich gar nicht
weiterdenken dann brauche ich gar nicht
schauen wie sie sich irgendwie auch
etwas beziehen kann
das ist ziemlich klar weiter gleich
vorliegt so etwas verleiten dass in den
besitz einer so scheinbaren kunst allen
unseren erkenntnissen die form des
verstandes zu geben ob man gleich in
anziehung des inhalts der selben noch
sehr leer und arm sein mag dass jene
allgemeine logik die bloß ein kamen zur
beurteilung ist gleichsam wir in organen
zu wirklichen hervorbringung wenigstens
zum blendwerk von objektiven
behauptungen gebracht gebraucht und
mithin in der tat dadurch gemäß braucht
worden ist dazu setzen die allgemeine
logik nun als vermeinte solga nun heißt
dialekt kennen sie einen philosophen der
ein werk geschrieben hat mit dem titel
organon es gibt zwei es gibt ein altes
organen und ein neues organ
wissen sie wir das alte organon
geschrieben hat organon ist ein fach
werkzeug also werkzeug zur erkenntnis
methodenlehre genau aristoteles und wer
hat das neue organ geschrieben was
jemand der neuzeit jemand ein engländer
bacon genau francis bacon hat das neue
organon geschrieben darin hat er sich
sehr kritisch mit aristoteles
auseinandergesetzt hat kritisiert bei
aristoteles die theologie das was die
zwecke in der welt gibt die theologische
weltbetrachtung wurde ersetzt durch eine
kausal mechanische welt betrachten es
gibt nur eine ursache wirkung und nicht
um zwecke theologie ist die zweck
ursächlichkeit die wir bei augustinus
hier schon gefunden hatten dann mit
diesem silber oder diesen falschen
silber das ist ein teleologischen
kontexten und davon wird jetzt nicht
mehr geredet man redet nur noch von
ursache und wirkung
und jetzt sagt kant die allgemeine logik
die methode unser denken auf
widersprüchlichkeit zu
prüfen ist nur ein vereintes organen die
logik hilft uns letztendlich gar nichts
wenn wir wirklich wissen wollen was
wahrheit ist
ja mehr noch schlimmer noch die logik
kann zu einem blendwerk von objektiven
behauptungen gebraucht und missbraucht
es braucht werden also man könnte dann
sagen wir das alles logisch kurrent
logisch widerspruchsfrei also haben wir
hier die wahrheit dann sagt kann das ist
die dialektik also eine allgemeine logik
als vermeinte sorgen also als angebliche
erkenntnis erkenntnis instrument sie
können sich bei den kattas auch sagt er
hat hier auch so ein bisschen hier sich
ganz viele methoden überlegt die methode
die methode tode geht das erreicht wird
das hat auch was von organon ja also ein
werkzeug wir brauchen methoden die
letztendlich bei descartes ja auch
logisch waren er hat gesagt wir müssen
alles zurückführen auf die einfachsten
prämissen der duh tief das hat was von
logik erkannt es hilft nichts bringt
nichts wenn der effekt bringt das gar
nichts das ist die dialektik ist ihnen
sich an die sieben freien künste
kennen sie die sieben freien künste in
der mittelalterlichen scholastik
tradition also können sie nur auf zehn
jahre
trivium die drei ersten jahr genau und
stadt logik kann man auch sagen
dialektik das war also genau dasselbe
ich schreibe auch hier also es gibt
sieben sieben freien künste
die musste man immer studieren bevor man
medizin theologie oder jurisprudenz
studieren konnte bevor man die studieren
konnte die hauptfächer ist ja heute
genau noch so wenn sie heute medizin
studieren haben sie ausgesorgt sind
natürlich auch extrem eingespannt
genauso sind jetzt in der theologie und
genauso sind der jurisprudenz das sind
alles sehr mächtige fächer sehr
traditionsreiche fächer und die sieben
freien kunst studieren zu können müssen
sie erst rhetorik grammatik und wie sie
sagt richtig logik oder dialektik das
ist zudem dass das tritium da kommt auch
das deutsche wort trivial her
trivial das ist ja trivial und dann geht
es weiter die das quad regierung wissen
sie noch ein paar weitere vier freie
künste fehlen noch gastronomie ja genau
geometrie musik
und
ja
das haben wir
genau genau meine ich auch wenn ich mich
nicht irre genau wenn ich mich nicht
irre ist das gehört das paar noch zu den
vier weiteren den kathrin da bin ich
glaube wir nicht mit der eta aber ich
glaube also das sind die zwei künstler
hier haben wir die dialektik die
dialektik ist die logik das ist da geht
es einfach darum im sinne der aristotle
aristotelischen logik dieser weise wie
man diskutiert so konträr sie kennt
welches logische quadrat die verhalten
sich verschiedene aussagen zueinander
sind sie kontradiktorisch denn sie
konträr sind so konträr usw
diese verschiedenen logischen
verhältnisse muss die dialektik und kann
sagte dialektik müssen wir sehr kritisch
betrachten der dialektik ist eigentlich
letztendlich wenn es um die wahrheit
erkenntnis geht nur ein blend werkzeug
die doppelt uns vor dass wir in unserer
logischen kohärenz schon in der wahrheit
wären dabei sind wir eigentlich nur in
einem logischen raum in einem logischen
allgemeinen logischen raum der noch viel
zu weit ist um wahrheit oder erkenntnis
im interessanten sinne zu ermöglichen
ich meine natürlich haben wir im rahmen
der dialektik mit wahrheiten das zu tun
was für wahrheit nochmal wiederholung
welche wahrheiten kann ich durch
dialektik produzieren oder bestätigen
oder erkennen ja genau tautologie
letztendlich auch vieles davon was
leibnitz uns aufgezeigt hat ja wenn ich
gleich es vergleich im nehmen kommt
gleich es raus und wendig gleiches zu
gleichem addiere kommt gleiches raus
oder der satz vom widerspruch und ich
kann nicht zugleich hier sein und dort
sein
klar aber würde kann sagen dass es nun
interessant das ist keine konkrete
kenntnis das ist nichts apostolisches
das zwar apriori ist weiß ich fordere
erfahrung aber es ist nichts ich muss
sagen synthetisches ist nicht
synthetisch es sagt nichts wirklich
interessant des hauses sagt nur was über
logische verhältnisse die sehr allgemein
sind aus sagt nicht wirklich
nachhaltiges aus das was kann dem
vorherigen zitat oder im vorherigen
zitat mit diesem inhalt bezeichnet hatte
also was er mit diesem positiven
positiven bedingung bezeichnet hatte und
von dieser lose form von der bloßen form
abgegrenzt hatte
es geht ihm um konkrete inhaltliche
erkenntnis und die ist eben synthetisch
das ist dieser fachbegriff dafür im
gegensatz zu analytisch ja also die
dialektik das ist verkannt jetzt
plötzlich problematisch geworden
zu verschieden auch die bedeutung ist in
der die alten dieser benennung einer
wissenschaft oder kunst sich bedienten
so kann man doch aus dem wirklichen
gebrauch derselben sicher abnehmen dass
sie bei ihnen nichts anders war als die
logik des scheins eine solistische kunst
seine unwissenheit ja auch seinem
vorsätzlichen blend werken der den
anstrich der wahrheit zu geben dass man
die methode gründlichkeit welche die
logik überhaupt vorschreibt nachahmte
und ihre tobi zur beschönigung jedes
lehrern vorgehens benutzt nun kann man
es als eine sichere und brauchbare
warnung anmerken dass die allgemeine
logik als organen betrachtet jederzeit
eine logik des scheins das ist
dialektisch sei denn da sie uns gar
nichts über den inhalt der erkenntnis
letzten nur bloß die formalen
bedingungen der übereinstimmung mit dem
verstanden welche übrigens in anziehung
dagegen ständig gänzlich gleichgültig
so muss die zumutung sich derselben als
eines werkzeugs organon zu gebrauchen um
seine kenntnisse wenigstens dem vorgeben
nach auszubreiten und zu erweitern
auf nichts als geschwätzigkeit
hinauslaufen alles was man will
mit einigem schein zu behaupten oder
auch nach belieben anzufechten logik
gibt uns kein sicheres kriterium für
wahrheit die ist viel zu allgemein die
logik gilt für alles mögliche für die
gesamten logischen raum für alles was in
der welt findet wir wollen aber konkrete
inhaltliche erkenntnissen nach kant die
synthetisch ist die gehalts erweitert
ist nicht nur analytisch ist und das
können wir eben mit der logik nicht
machen wenn wir es versuchen wollten
dann würden wir uns ein in eine
schamhafte geschäft begeben was er den
mittelalterlichen vorwirft history um
die elektrik logik des scheins hat mit
wahrheit gar nichts zu tun als eine bloß
definitorischen angelegenheit in
sicheren probierstand die kanzlei
erlangen wir dadurch nicht ja
ja richtig die werden wenn ich es recht
sein also platon bewundert cantz er
äußert sich sehr positiv über platon
aber im endeffekt würde eher sagen das
sind keine kritischen philosophen dies
sind alle der dialektik des scheins
unserer vernunft verhaftet die haben die
vernunft nicht genug kritisiert kann
sagt er macht eine kritik der reinen
vernunft und bestimmte ideen von gott
seele und sterblichkeit von den
plattform zb sehr sehr sage jetzt mal
naiv spricht die seele ist unsterblich
gemacht beweise der unsterblichkeit der
seele würde kann sagen das ist ein
typischer fall von dialektik platon da
hatte ich deine vernunft an der nase
herumgeführt
da hatte ich da eine vernunft sich
getäuscht eine vernunft glaubt zwar dass
es oder es kann vielleicht zeigen dass
es logisch widerspruchsfrei ist oder
vielleicht sogar irgendwie einleuchtend
ist mit evidenz aber es reicht nicht aus
damit die sache war
du musst deine vernunft kritisieren du
musst aufpassen würde kanzleramt und
dass da eine vernünftige nichts vormacht
also verkannt wäre plan auch einen ein
dialektischer im schlechten sinn
aber jetzt kann ist trotz allem dem sehr
positiv gegenüber plattform eingestellt
ja kann würde nur sagen die platonischen
ideen die können wir so nicht annehmen
das ist naiv platon hat sich zu wenig
gedanken gemacht über die bedingung der
möglichkeit die erkenntnis von ideen da
von den dingen der welt laden hat hier
dieses objekt nicht genug kritisiert
leitung ist gleich auf die wahrheit der
objekte auf gegangen hat keine reflexion
auf das objekt unternommen deswegen ist
das ein problem
ja und das mittelalter sowieso das kommt
noch schlechter weg
genau genau also nach kant wäre platon
und alle anderen großen metaphysiker
letztendlich nur ihre während ihrer dem
schein oder logo ihrer vernunft erliegen
die hätten eben bis hin zu so gutgläubig
der vernunft folge geleistet
das ist eine ganz große erkenntnisse vom
kanton eine interessante these
jedenfalls dass die vernunft und selbst
täuschen kann
das ist ein riesenfortschritt das ist
ein ganz kritisches denken die vernunft
selbst kann uns täuschen
wir können selbst und täuschen rationale
selbsttäuschung das ist ganz spannend
auch in der gegenwärtigen debatte
wir dürfen nicht zu sehr sollten die
vernunft nicht irgendwie abschaffen
ganze gar nicht aber wir sollten immer
schauen wo die vernunft in grenzen
gesetzt werden muss wo wir zur vernunft
noch erfahrung brauchen ein anderes
moment zu treten muss
wie genau das aussieht das wird jetzt
gleich sehen das hat er nämlich noch ein
anderes werk geschrieben das ist die
logik aus 1800 ich glaube sogar dass das
nur mit schriften sind das sind nur
vorlesungs mitschriften das hat er
meines wissens gar nicht veröffentlicht
das sind mit schriften seiner studenten
die dann herausgegeben wurden die
vorlesung ist aus dem jahr 1800 und da
ist es ganz ähnliche liz auch mal vor
was er sagt zum thema wahrheit eine
haupt vollkommenheit des erkenntnis ist
ja die wesentliche und unzertrennliche
bedingung aller vollkommenheit desselben
ist die wahrheit wahrheit sagt man
besteht übereinstimmung der erkenntnis
mit dem gegenstand dieser bloßen wort
erklärung zufolge soll also mein meine
erkenntnis um als wahr zu gelten mit dem
objekt übereinstimmen und kann ich aber
das objekt nur mit meinem erkenntnisse
vergleichen dadurch dass ich es erkenne
meine erkenntnis sollte sich also selbst
bestätigen welches arbeit zur wahrheit
noch lange nicht hinreichend ist denn da
das objekt außer mir und erkenntnis ist
so kann ich immer noch nur beurteilen ob
meine erkenntnis vom objekt mit meiner
erkenntnis vom objekt übereinstimmen
ein solcher zierke im erklären nannten
die alten die allele also durcheinander
heißt übersetzt und wirklich wurde
dieser fehler auch immer den logischen
von den skeptikern vorgeworfen
wir bemerkten es verhalte sich mit jener
erklärung der wahrheit so wie wenn
jemand vor gericht eine aussage truhe
und sich dabei auf einen zeugen beruft
ihn niemand kennen der sich aber dadurch
glaubwürdig machen wolle dass er
behauptet der welcher ihn zum zeugen
aufgerufen sei ein ehrlicher mann die
beschuldigung war allerdings gegründet
nur ist die auflösung der gedachten
aufgabe schlechthin für jeden menschen
womöglich noch mal wiederholen worin
besteht nach kant jetzt hier der zirkel
in erklären dieser gewöhnlichen
auffassung von wahrheit als
übereinstimmung der kenntnis von dem
gegenstand
genauer also dass im stern scheint der
satz ist hier nun kann ich aber das
objekt als war nur mit meinem
erkenntnisse nun kann ich aber das
objekt nur mit meinem erkenntnisse
vergleichen dadurch dass ich es erkenne
das ist also das problem des regresses
oder das zirkels ich muss meine
erkenntnis selbst erkennen kann ich
meine erkenntnis erkennen muss ich nicht
die erkenntnis mein erkenntnis wieder
erkennen und so weiter und so fort
das scheint hier das problem dass man ja
ja das wäre jetzt diese theoretisiert
formulieren ist die konsens theorie der
wahrheit die kante dieser form nicht
vertreten würde
also sie haben schon recht also kann
braucht seine art von inter
subjektivität von anerkennungs
verhältnissen aber diese anerkennungs
verhältnisse sind nicht bei kann so zu
denken dass wir hier jetzt eine
faktische gemeinschaft haben wie in
diesem raum mit 30 teilnehmern und wir
uns alle darüber einig sind dass jetzt
hier ein laptop auf dem tisch steht
so versteht kann jetzt nicht diesen
konsens sind es eher ein intra
subjektiver konsens also das subjekt
stimmt sich selbst zu der wahrheit genau
allgemeingültigkeit ist bei kant aber
eher logisch zu denken
logisch als sie jetzt nicht im sinne von
consensus es ist es hat etwas strenger
das ist ein strenger begriff von
allgemeingültigkeit
genau genau
also genau also das ist jetzt eine
kritik einer bestimmten vorstellung von
wahrheit die kant nicht teilt aber da
hat aber natürlich auch eine theorie
gewalt auf die kommune also kannte es
ein wahrheit optimist ist kein
wahrheitsgehalt kritisiert eben zunächst
bestimmte vorstellungen von wahrheit die
seiner ansicht nach die sache verfehlen
und verfehlt verfehlen tut einem als
theorie dann ihr anliegen wenn sie in
einem zirkel gerät wenn sie also
wahrheit ganz naiv als übereinstimmung
unserer erkenntnis zu dem objekt ansieht
und sich nicht genug gedanken darüber
macht was eigentlich im subjekt
stattfindet in unserem erkenntnisprozess
wenn wir erkennen kann ist der meinung
die wahrheit der wahrheit' grund einer
eines sachverhalts liegt einerseits in
der allgemeinen logik das hat mir schon
das ist aber nur die notwendige
bedingung der zweite grund ist der dass
es mit unserem spezifischen verhältnis
zu tun hat wie erkennen dass
objektivität die objekte selbst
konstruiert die objekte dürfen nach kant
nicht unabhängig von der erkenntnis
gedacht werden es um objekte werden
durch die erkenntnis erst zu objekten
also erkenntnis ist verkannt nichts was
ich dem objekt letztendlich auf diese
weise annähert das erkannt das ist sehr
cool er das geht nicht sind etwas was
das zu erkennende erst als solches
möglich macht und nicht nur möglich
macht so wirklich macht erkenntnis macht
das objekt zum objekt also objektivität
durch subjektivität der mir beides fehlt
er aneinander zusammenbringen ändert
sich das gesamte setting innerhalb
dessen korrespondenz gedacht werden kann
es war da hinten die meldung glaube ich
genau das ist jetzt so kohle oder und
infiniti quick press
ich glaube dass er dieses problem hier
in dem text so anspringen ja das ist
richtig also kann hat es sagt es
jedenfalls hegel hegel würde sagen kann
du kommst genau in den selben zweck
rhein-pegel sagt er aber man muss ja
bedenken dass eben verkannt erkenntnis
nicht in dem sinne zu verstehen ist dass
es nur eine selbst selbstbezug ist
erkenntnisses verkannt nicht nur das
herstellen eines selbstbezug als ob da
schon ein objekt gegeben ist auch dass
man referiert sind das objekt ist bevor
erkenntnis noch nicht stattgefunden hat
noch nicht objekt erkenntnis formiert
sich objektivität formiert sich durch
die erkenntnis erst hindurch also nicht
so dass erkenntnis und objekt getrennt
sind objektivität ist eine folge der
erkenntnis objektivität ist nicht vor
der erkenntnis dar so nur durch die
erkenntnis das ist so die stoßrichtung
von kann
deswegen kann er diesen zirkel argument
hier entgehen er sagt das objekt liegt
noch gar nicht vor
bevor ich nicht erkannt habe
wichtig und dann kann man wie hegel ist
tot fragen wie kann ich denn die
bedingung der möglichkeit meine
erkenntnis erkennen muss ich nicht die
erkenntnis wieder erkennen und so weiter
das ist richtig dieser zweite vorwurf
der kommt dann bei häkelt sehr sehr
zentral ja aber wir haben hier schon ein
vorteilen nach kann jedenfalls gelöst
dass wir verhalten objektivität nicht
mehr als etwas naiv vorliegendes
betrachten auf dass sich unsere
erkenntnis zu beziehen hat sondern weit
oder objektivität ist ein moment oder
eine folge unserer erkenntnis ist es ist
nichts was davon getrennt
ja
ja also kannte hat willkommen jetzt sehr
tiefe müssen da gar nicht so tief
einsteigen kann hat noch eine these des
dinges ansicht das ist ganz schwierig
wie man das zu verstehen hat es wäre
also das ding wie es unabhängig von
unserer erkenntnis ist
hier kann man sich fragen ist das nicht
innerhalb von kants theorie
widersprüchlich weil erkannt eigentlich
wie wir gerade gesagt haben das sagen
scheint dass individualität oder
substantially tät erst durch die
erkenntnis zustande kommt kann dann ein
ding an sich überhaupt existieren
das problem ist es nach kant müssen wir
um etwas zu erkennen einerseits unsere
logik unserem verstand benutzen mit
seinen kategorien wie substanz
kausalität da sind alle strukturen die
gegenständen ihre gegenständlichkeit
geben substanz nicht ist eine kategorie
dadurch kann ich einzelne dinge als
individuen in meiner erfahrung heraus
picken
das problem ist nach kant muss immer
noch die anschauung dazu kommen also ich
muß begriffe haben oder kategorien wie
substanz dazu muss aber noch die sims
daten kommen zum beispiel dazu sagt dass
ein weißer tisch der waren diese farbe
weiß hat diese sind es qualität weiß die
ist nach kant nicht auf das objekt
zurückzuführen das leistet das objekt
nicht das objekt leistet in seinem
erkenntnis wo die formalen bedingungen
also wie gegenständlichkeit wie
kausalität solche formalen strukturen
man kann sich fragen woher kommt jetzt
bitteschön die farbe geruch und so
weiter und da lässt kann eben eine tür
offen und sagt das muss von den dingen
an sich kommen
das problem ist wenn man sagt das kommt
daher legen wir eigentlich wieder die
kategorie die kausalität zugrunde und
wenden sie auf das dient sich an was wir
gar nicht dürften weil das ding an sich
kein gegenstand mögliche erfahrung ist
da wo das wurde von jacobi einen denker
der klassischen deutschen philosophie
sehr scharfsinnig gezeigt dass kannte
eine große probleme bekommen wir müssen
jedenfalls erklären woher sind es daten
kommen wie weiß wie gelb farben aber
auch andere sinnes daten die kommen
nämlich nach kant nicht aus unsere
erkennenden subjektivität und da wäre
ein möglicher kandidat zu sagen es ist
dass dinge an sich wie es eben absolut
existiert unabhängig von uns
erkenntnis bedingungen dann könnten eben
nur von dingen für uns sprechen es gibt
die dinge an sich und es gibt die dinge
wie sie für uns sinn alles was wir in
unserer erfahrung haben sie die dinge
für uns würde wahrheit und erkenntnis
nur für den bereich der dinge für uns
geld ist eine riesen debatte müssen wir
gar nicht mehr detail gehen das würde
jetzt zu weit führen was wichtig ist es
dass eben die formalen strukturen die
objektivität als objekt der tisch kann
eine farbe haben das ist ziemlich egal
als objekt interessiert uns nur seine
substanz seine individualität seinen
objekthaften die wird durch die
kategorie der substanz gestiftet und die
kategorie der substanz die stammt aus
dem subjekt und die finden wir nicht in
der welt vor das ist so die der trick
bei katja
ja haben die anderen teilnehmer dazu
eine idee
ja
genau also da ist kann dann doch ein
bisschen platonischer indem er sagt wir
haben alle in uns kategorien kann nennt
sie nicht ideen wie bei platon kann hat
auch den begriff der idee aber die ideen
begriff ist sehr problematisch weil er
den bereich der logik des scheins
betrifft der dialektik von dem wir
vorher gesprochen haben hat aber
kategorie kategorien sind letztendlich
erkenntnis musste die jedes objekt und
zwar nicht empirisch gedacht nicht
anthropologisch kann spricht auch nie
von menschen und seine erkenntnis es
spricht immer nur von endlichen
wesentlichen vernunft wesen da könnten
auch andere außerirdische darunter
fallen es ist nicht anthropologisch zu
verstehen also jedes endlicher vernunft
wesen hat eine subjektivität struktur
die bestimmte kategorien gesetzt
und die sind für alle endlichen
erkenntnis objekte klar vernunft diese
substanz kausalität diese kategorien
haben wir und sagt die legen wir in die
dinge hinein und dadurch erkennen wir
sie und das hat eine gewisse ähnlichkeit
zu platons die händler an wir erinnern
uns an die ideen die wir mal geschaut
und dadurch erkennen wir die dinge in
der bild aber wichtig ist hervorzuheben
dass es kann nicht um den menschen geht
er macht keine anthropologie sonst eine
transzendentale philosophie es geht um
die grundstrukturen unseres erkenntnis
apparats unendlichen erkenntnis ab
es gibt ja noch unendliche erkenntnis
wesen nach kant gott zum beispiel
vielleicht auch engel bin ich mir nicht
sicher bei thomas von aquin und kommen
auch noch engel ins spiel
hier gelten eben nur endlich vernunft
wesen wo eben menschen dazu zählen aber
vielleicht auch außerirdische ist ja
logisch nicht ausgeschlossen also das
problem hier der wieder zirkular i tät
der korrespondenz theorie es fragt sich
nämlich hier
ob und inwiefern ist ein sicheres
allgemeines und in der anwendung
brauchbares kriterium der wahrheit gebe
denn das soll die frage was ist wahrheit
bedeuten
aha definiert wahrheit jetzt die
wahrheitsfrage völlig anders es geht
also nicht darum
was wahrheit ist also die frage was ist
wahrheit heißt nicht nach kant wie
definieren wir wahrheit also eine
mögliche alte antwort auf die frage wer
wahrheit ist die übereinstimmung uns
verstanden es mit der welt beide ist
übereinstimmung unsere position mit den
tatsachen wahrheit ist die angleichung
unseres verstandes an die dinge das
navigations theorie und so weiter das
ist nach kant rein definitorischen geht
es jetzt darum letztendlich das der
wahrheit mit kriterien thet mit einem
kriterium mit erkenntnis verbinden
denn das soll die frage was ist wahrheit
bedeuten und diese wichtige frage
entscheiden zu können müssen wir das was
in unserem erkenntnisse zur materie
derselben gehört und auf das objekt sich
bezieht von dem was die bloße form als
diejenige bedienen betrifft ohne welche
eine erkenntnis gar keine erkenntnis
überhaupt sein würde unterscheiden mit
rücksicht auf diesen unterschied
zwischen dem der objektiven materialen
und der subjektiven formalen beziehung
in unserem erkenntnisse zerfällt daher
die obige frage in die zwei besonderen
erstens gibt es ein allgemeines
materials und gibt es ein allgemeines
formales kriterium der wahrheit
das ist jetzt also spannend diese
unterscheidung zwischen formen materie
jetzt schauen mal was kant dazu sagt ein
allgemeines material es geht eben der
wahrheit ist nicht möglich es sogar in
sich selbst widersprechen
denn als ein allgemeines für alle
objekte überhaupt gültiges müsste es von
allem unterschiede derselben völlig
abstrahieren und doch auch zugleich als
ein material das kriterium jedem auf
diesen unterschied gehen um bestimmen zu
können ob ein erkenntnis gerade mit dem
meeting in objekte worauf es bezogen
wird und nicht mit irgendeinem objekt
überhaupt somit eigentlich gar nichts
gesagt wäre übereinstimmen
diese übereinstimmung ein erkenntnis mit
demjenigen bestimmten objekte worauf sie
bezogen wird muss aber die materiale
wahrheit bestehen denn eine erkenntnis
welches in anziehung eines objektes war
ist kein beziehung auf andere objekte
falsch seien es daher ungereimt ein
allgemeines materials kriterium der wahl
zu fordern dass von allem unterschiede
der objekte zugleich abstrahieren und
auch nicht abstrahieren sollte könnte
das noch mal passieren dass es ein
bisschen schwierig was ist jetzt der
grund dafür dass kann zack sein
allgemeines materials kriterium der
wahrheit nicht möglich ist
genau also individualität von objekten
die den wird so eine allgemeine theorie
nicht gerecht haben sie noch andere
gründe darin gefunden also wahrheiten
oder erkenntnis muss immer konkret seien
ja über eine bestimmte erkenntnis eine
bestimmte ware brauchen konkrete
kriterien
hier ist nur in schönen satz denn eine
erkenntnis welches in ansehung eines
objektes weiß kann in beziehungen auf
andere objekte falsch sein allgemeines
müssen wahrheit immer konkrete
individuell verschieden verschieden
erkenntnisse und dass wir müssen weit
auch nach dem objekt richten sagte er
das würde bedeuten von allem
unterschiede der objekte zugleich
abstrahieren und auch nicht abstrahieren
und richtet sich immer nach konkreten
objekten die sind verschieden
so war es auch so könnte man sich
vorstellen ja ja wir müssen immer
konkret nach dem objekt fragen
ja wahrheit muss jedenfalls immer so ein
konkretes moment in sich haben so ein
moment was individualität oder genau die
objektivität gerecht wird und das heißt
es kann jetzt nicht nur diese substanz
kategorie sein die ja für alle dinge
gleiche wäre also wir brauchen immer
auch hier noch jetzt endlich anschauung
das ist noch so gut wir brauchen immer
noch so was von außen was dann
individualität ermöglicht anschauen und
begriffs verkanntes entscheidend begriff
ist das allgemeine was im subjekt blickt
kategorien und die anschauung ist das
was von außen kommt was man zu treten
muss es bisschen kompliziert ist und
weiter ist nun aber die frage nach
allgemein formalen kriterien der
wahrheit so ist die entscheidung sehr
leicht dass es dergleichen allerdings
geben können denn die formale wahrheit
besteht lediglich in der
zusammenstellung der erkenntnis mit sich
selbst bei gänzliche abstraktion von
allen objekten insgesamt und von allem
unterschiede derselben und die allgemein
formalen kriterien der wahrheit sind
demnach nichts anders als allgemeine
logischen merkmale der übereinstimmung
erkenntnis mit sich selbst oder welches
eine leihe ist mit den allgemeinen
gesetzen des verstandes und der vernunft
also die formale wahrheit das ist jetzt
wieder das was wir vorhin als das
organon hatten
das ist jetzt endlich unabhängig von den
objekten in ihrer materialität naja das
war hier also hier das material
kriterium betrifft objekte in der welt
und den müssen wir eben immer gerecht
werden in ihrer individualität während
die formalen kriterien der wahrheit sehr
gut allgemein sein dürfen weil sie eben
letztendlich nichts mit den dingen in
der welt zu tun habt hat sondern wir
gesehen haben nur den logischen raum
betrifft die widerspruchsfreiheit
insofern können wir da auf jedes objekt
es anwenden das unabhängig von der
individualität logische merkmale die
erkennt übereinstimmung der erkenntnis
mit sich selbst das heißt er definiert
hier jetzt kohärenz als korrespondenz
der erkenntnis mit sich selbst
was ich hier jetzt übereinstimmung
erkenntnis mit sich selbst nennt hier
bezeichnet ist letztendlich kohärenz
theologische cordon sanitaire also ist
das problem ist jetzt dass ein formales
normale kriterium ein allgemeines
material material das kriterium
allgemeines material sgt das ist das
problem jetzt hier das macht dann
letztendlich wirklich erkenntnis möglich
während wie wir schon eingangs gesehen
hatten die bloßen formalen kriterien der
wahrheit biologische widersprüchlichkeit
eben nur die dass der negative
probierstand sind die conditio sine qua
non die notwendige bedingung überhaupt
entscheiden ist die frage nach dem
materialen kriterium also wenn es um die
objekte geht das ist die frage nach dem
material formale sache da geht es nun
die logische struktur unserer aussage ob
die wieder- oder unsere theorien ob die
widersprüchlich sind ne selbst wenn sie
nicht wieder sportlich sind heißt es
nicht dass die theorien war sind das ist
das problem
dann bleiben wir nur definitorischen
wir müssen hin kommen zu den objekten
wir müssen von unserer bloße theorie hin
zu den objekten kommen ohne dabei wie
denn ein zirkel zu geraten das ist die
herausforderung diese formalen
allgemeinen kriterien sind zwar freilich
zur objektiven wahrheit nicht
hinreichend aha also er sagt jetzt hier
es gibt die formale wahrheit ist die
logische widerspruchsfreiheit tautologie
dass eine formale wahrheit einsatz ist
war aufgrund seiner bloßen form alle
junggesellen sind unverheiratet es war
interessant wenn ich gleich ist zugleich
mit tutu kommt gleich ist raus es war
aber irgendwie nicht sonderlich
interessant ich kann nicht zugleich
diesem ort hier sein und zugleich an
diesem ort ist seien es auch war aber
irgendwie auch nicht sonderlich
interessant da mache ich keine konkrete
erkenntnisse wenn ich auf solche sätze
referiere weil ich einfach nur
allgemeine logische verhältnisse klären
die ich völlig beliebig übertragen könnt
ihr auf alle sachverhalte
ich kann nicht sogleich hier stehen und
hier das pult dieses pult kann ich
zugleich hier stehen und hier für sie
alle gilt es auch keine konkrete
erkenntnisse
ja also diese formalen allgemeinen
kriterien sind zwar freilich zu
objektiven wahrheit nicht hinreichend
aber sie sind doch als die container
senioren sind gewohnt derselben
anzusehen das hatten wir schon diesem
ersten text aus der b- auflage der
kritik der reinen vernunft denn vor der
frage ob die erkenntnis mit dem objekt
zusammen stimme muss die frage vorher
gehen ob sie mit sich selbst der form
nach zusammen stimme und diese die sache
logik das heißt also wir bevor wir nach
der korrespondenz fragen der wahrheit ob
die erkenntnis mit dem die erkenntnis
mit dem objekt zusammen stimme das ist
die korrespondenz muss die frage vorher
gehen ob sie mit sich selbst der form
nach zusammen stimme als er hier geht es
nicht mehr um übereinstimmung
letztendlich seien um zusammen stimmung
um zusammen stimmung und zusammen
stimmung ist kohärenz und dies ist die
sache lobt die formalen kriterien der
wahrheit in der logik sind erstens das
hat des widerspruchs zweitens der satz
das zureichend grund es durch den
ersteren ist die logische möglichkeit
durch den letzten die logische
wirklichkeit
eines erkenntnisses bestimmt das ist
jetzt interessant sehen sie hier nehmen
zu einem anderen behandelten denker
er hatte ganz ähnlich so argumentiert ja
leiten jetzt genau wir hatten da sogar
vier punkte gefunden sich noch vier
verhältnisse bei leibnitz hier nimmt er
nur zwei des widerspruchs was ist das
haben sie beispiel eines ein beispiel
für den satz des widerspruchs
belieben ist immer das herz des
widerspruchs was besagt ja was ist
einfach ein widerspruch formulieren sie
mal einen satz der dem satz widerspruchs
er liegt oder gehorcht wie auch immer
ganz hinten ja
genau genau also einfach contra dick zu
die kontraktion sie können nicht etwas
behaupten und es zugleich zugleich meint
nicht zeitlich soeben in derselben
logischen logischen setting zugleich
bestreiten
das ist ein widerspruch des satzes
gespuckt
genau das wäre sogar dann eine anwendung
einer reduktion absurdum
ich nehme erst mal das andere an als
mitglied war wohl der meinung es gibt
unendlich viele primzahlen
er nimmt an es gibt endlich viele
primzahlen nimmt diese macht diese
aussage und zeigt an dass wenn ich davon
ausgehe dass es endlich viele primzahlen
gibt dass ich dann ein widerspruch
geraten
und daraus folgt es muss unendlich viele
geben so könnte man beweisen dass es
unendlich viele primzahlen geben musste
und dann würde man auch auf den satz des
widerspruchs rekurrieren bei einer
reduktion sie diese natürlich
widerspruches ist das ist so der haupt
logische faktoren kontradiktorische
widersprüche und wie verstehen sie eine
zweiten satz deshalb das zureichend
grundes ja so könnte man es verstehen ja
wie verstehen sie jetzt das kannte dazu
sagt der letztere der satz der logischen
des zu reichen grundes bestimmt die
logische wirklichkeit eines erkennen an
erkenntnis
des logischen des zu reichen grundes
heißt eigentlich nur alles hat eine
ursache also alles muss eine ursache
haben
als eine ursache haben muss
das ist eigentlich auch nicht so ganz
klar ich meine zum beispiel wie ist es
mit gott da hat er eine ursache was
würde das könnte man sagen
um dennoch hier den satz des zu reichen
grundes gelten zu lassen ja genau causa
sowie selbst ursächlichkeit natürlich
kann man sich dann fragen kann es so was
wie eine selbst ursächlichkeit überhaupt
geben
unterlegt so was wie der wirt gefangenen
causa zu ihn nicht dem satz des
widerspruchs das ist das nicht ein
widerspruch in sich spannende frage also
dass zu reichen grundes alle jede
wirkung hat eine ursache und ich etwas
habe muss es einen grund haben und
deswegen ist es trifft auch die
wirklichkeit eines erkennen ist weil ich
ja von etwas wirklich im ausgeh von dem
ich dann auf einen grund schließen darf
was auch immer der grund ist aber es
muss einen grund haben
alles muss eine ursache haben ja das
sind die formalen kriterien damit kann
ich aber noch keine konkreten also alle
konkreten erkenntnisse alle objekte
unterliegen diesen zwei sätzen
ja der logische raum also alles was ich
erkennen kann muss eine ursache haben
und es muss widerspruchsfrei sein
ja
genau er sagt also der satz zu erreichen
grund ist bestimmt die logische
wirklichkeit ist die wirklichkeit das
heißt es ist letztendlich auf das
objektbezogen objektivität wird markant
durch subjektivität geleistet aber jetzt
eben auf eine material weise also
insofern haben sie recht ein wichtiger
punkt ist dass jetzt interessant genau
wie sie spielen auf folgendes an glaube
ich sie meinen wie ist es mit der
kategorie die kausalität und dem zu
einem grunde genau genau die kategorie
der kausalität ist verkannt ja etwas was
im subjekt liegt das ist wurde frage das
darf offensichtlich nicht identifiziert
werden
das ist was verschiedenes genau wie
genau man es gleich auseinander halten
muss dass eine spannende frage
genau das geht nach kant nicht also der
das wäre nach kant letztendlich wieder
eine dialektik man könnte jetzt sagen
das hat das zuger grund sagt das alles
also abgesehen von seiner individualität
alles schlechthin
das ist eine ursache haben muss ganz
allgemein gesagt dann können wir das bis
ins unendliche zurückgehen und können
sagen es muss aber doch einen
allerersten grund geben werde es kein
allerersten grund gäbe dann könnte es
nichts wirkliches geben so so
argumentiert kanten einer stelle also
jetzt nicht dass er wirklich dieser
überzeugung ist aber er sagt so könnte
man das denken und dann ist man sehr
schnell dabei und gottesbeweis zu
konstruieren und zu sagen es muss einen
ersten grund geben durch den alle
möglichen kausalketten in gang gesetzt
er sagt kann das können wir nicht machen
wirklich erkenntnis wahrheit können wir
nicht über diese zwei sätze hier
begründen
das ist allein ein allgemeines formales
kriterium und eine gute frage von ist es
dann wie verhält sich der satz ist zu
recht im grunde ist der was formales ist
zu der kategorie der kausalität in uns
die nach kant dann letztendlich zusammen
mit der anschauung das material ist
konstituieren
eine spannende frage wo man darf es
nicht gleichsetzen ist eine ist eine
transzendentale logik das betrifft alle
kategorien die wir uns im subjekt haben
qualität ist eine transportable
kategorie transzendentale logik von der
normalen logik muss man unterscheiden
kann
zwei verschiedene dinge
ja das eine spannende frage ich denke
man darf wichtig eine spannende frage
wieder zureichende grund genau zu
verstehen ist
das geht jetzt daraus nicht direkt
hervor er sagt hier nur die logische
wirklichkeit eines erkenntnis das ist
wichtig logische wirklichkeit eben nicht
die reale wirklichkeit also es betrifft
jetzt nicht die kausalität im strengen
sinne
das wäre die reale möglichkeit qualität
ist der subjektivität verdanke ich kann
oder haben sie ein anderes verstehen
dass das zureichend grunde alles was
geschieht muss eine ursache h und das
ist der satz das zureichend grund das
hat einen grund
nichts geschieht grundlos ja
so könnte man es auch verstehen ja ich
kann ja sagen dass eine logische
folgerung beziehung keine kausale
beziehung ist also haben wir logische
folgerung beziehung sind die können
vielleicht die sind einfach viel
allgemeiner
die betreffenden logische übergänge von
verschiedenen positionen zueinander
die frage ist dann gehen wir das im
sinne dieses zureichende grundes
verstehen muss könnte vielleicht sagen
es muss so was wie axiome geben von auf
die sich alle alle schlüssel oder alle
weiteren erkenntnisse zurückführen
lassen vielleicht
mir scheint dass es zu einem grundes
doch sowas zu sein wie alles was
geschieht hat einen grund
ja
ja schon richtig eigentlich glaube sie
haben recht dass dieser begriff höchst
problematisch ist aber er spricht hier
noch von der formalen allgemein von
einem normalen allgemeinen kriterium es
darf nur der logische raums sein das
betrifft nichts raum zeitliches verkannt
also sozusagen kausalität wäre etwas was
nur in raum und zeit vor kann kommen
kann
und hier ist er nur im logischen raum
der nicht räumlich zeitlich zu verstehen
ist als wäre das eine struktur die noch
viel allgemeiner als kausalität ist bei
kausalität immer raum und zeit
voraussetzt würde er hier sagen der
sattelzug eines grundes fundiert
vielleicht totalität sanität kann nicht
sein ohne dass den satz 2 des bundes
gibt
das heißt aber nicht dass kausalität mit
dem satz das zureichend grundes das
prinzip identisch ist
weil es nicht auf frauen zeitstrukturen
passiert alles noch viel formaler ist ja
jetzt haben wir vorhin gesprochen
schwierig schwierig also meines wissens
ist der satz funktionen grund einfach
der alles was ist hat eine ursache
geschieht und dann haben aber das
problem dass da wieder die kausalität
einkommen aber es ist ein guter punkt
das müssen wir müssen wir auf müssen wir
auf dem schirm weiter haben das ist ein
guter punkt wie fern da nicht materiale
momente hinein kommen kann kommt dem er
entgegen dem er sagt hier ist die
wirklichkeit eines erkenntnisses
bestimmt wirklichkeit ist nicht mehr nur
eine möglichkeit sind wir schon recht
konkret guter punkt müssen im hinterkopf
behalten schließt weiter zu logischen
wahrheit eines erkenntnisses gehört
nämlich erstens das ist logisch
möglichkeit das heißt sich nicht
widersprechen
dieses kennzeichen der innerlichen
logischen wahrheit ist aber nur negativ
denn eine kenntnis wenig widerspricht
jetzt zwar falsch wenn es sich aber
nicht widerspricht nicht alle mal war
das ist klar
zweitens dass es logisch gegründet sei
das heißt dass es gründe habe und b
nicht falsche folgen habe
dieses zweite den logischen zusammenhang
eines erkenntnisses mit gründen und
folgen betreffende kriterium der
äußerlichen logischen wahrheit oder der
rationalität des erkenntnisses ist
positiv verstehen sie das jetzt auf
diese zwei sätze bezogen hier auf
erstens zweitens
also offensichtlich scheint der hier
gehts weiter
diesen satz zu lesen ich diesen zweiten
satzes zu reichen grundes hierüber
logische begründung logische
begründetheit zu verstehen
also es gibt gründe die zu dieser
aussage führen ja dann wäre das klarer
von kausalität unterschieden eines
logische gründe werden wenn wir jetzt
hier zweitens auf den satz hier das zur
bundes beziehen dann wäre es rein
logisch gegründeten es muss sagen eine
rechtfertigung geben und es kann nichts
falsch daraus folgen
ihr könnt nichts falsches daraus
ableiten also könnte es mit aktionen
oder zu vergleichen logische axiome die
alles fundieren
genau so war es ja also dass der ersatz
des zureichenden grundes und noch mal
zurück zu gehen jetzt nicht so sehr
kausal zu verstehen ist sondern die
prozessqualität den übergang von
verschiedenen sätzen aufeinander
bezeichnen
das hat des widerspruchs wäre
letztendlich nicht so sehr in diesen
relationen zu denken so ein angesichts
eines satzes wie sie maßen synchro
logisch synchron und nicht logisch
diakon auch wenn man von der zeit her in
der logik nicht sprechen darf
aber logik hat was prozess so alles was
nicht zeitlich ist dieses prozess orale
könnte dann dieses nicht zeitlich nicht
kausale prozessor aale in der logik
könnte dann den satz könnte dann den
satz des zufälligen grundes betrifft
also das scheint mir jetzt auch im
nachhinein plausibler zu sein als dass
eine zu große nähe der kausalität zu
bringen eine kausalität wie sie richtig
gesagt haben als er das objekt betrifft
in der konkreten erkenntnisse und nicht
diese logische struktur also es geht
dann wohl offensichtlich um folgerung
beziehungen und hier gelten folgende
regeln erstens aus der wahrheit der
folge lässt sich auf die wahrheit des
erkenntnisses als grundes schließen aber
nur negativ in eine falsche folge aus
einer erkenntnis fließt so ist die
erkenntnis selbst falsch wenn der grund
war wäre so müsste die folge auch wahr
sein weil die folge durch den grund
bestimmt wird
man kann aber nicht umgekehrt schließen
dann keine falsche folge aus einem
erkenntnisse fließen ist es war nun kann
das einen falschen grunde ware folgen
ziehen
es geht jetzt praktisch letztendlich um
gültig und schlüssig kennen sie den
unterschied zwischen gültig und
schlüssig der logik mit prämissen haben
sie das nicht gehalten der logik bei
herrn leid gibt gültig und schlüssig
hmm
es geht um folgende punkte sind die
richtige richtung es geht um die frage
es sind die prämissen wahr oder falsch
glaube ich kann natürlich falschen
prämissen ansätzen die also nicht wahr
sind kann sie aber als wir annehmen und
dann daraus was auch logisch korrekte
weise ab heraus leiten
dann habe ich eine konklusion die nach
logisch korrekten methoden gewonnen
wurde die aber falsch ist weil halt die
prämissen falsch sind
es geht eben um diesen unterschied
zwischen folgerung beziehungen die
korrekt sind die wahrheit vermögen und
um die prämissen die letztendlich alles
tragen an denen alles von den alles
abhängt wie die falsch
das könnte damit gemeint sein so was
zweiter sind alle folgen eines
erkenntnisses wahl sind so ist das
erkenntnis auch war
dann wäre nur etwas falsches im
erkenntnisse so müsste auch eine falsche
folge stattfinden haben sie dazu noch
bemerkt das ist jetzt sehr sehr
technisch der sie formal
sonst würde ich sagen einfach mal weiter
das ist jetzt nicht so zentral wie wird
es nämlich während dieser logischen
logischer schluss arten bestimmt als aus
der folge lässt sich zwar auf einen
grund schließen aber ohne diesen grund
bestimmen zu können nur aus dem
inbegriff aller folgen anleihen kann auf
einen bestimmten grund schließen dass
dieser der ware sei die erste schluss
art nach welcher die folge nur ein
negativ und indirekt sogar nicht das
kriterium der wahrheit eines erkenntnis
sein kann heißt in der logik die ab
agogische modus tollen haben sie das
schon modus polens modus sollen ja also
wenn a und b wenn nicht mehr nicht
das ist toll ins brauchen jetzt nicht
weiter eingehen das betrifft jetzt nicht
so sehr
unsere wahrheit theorien es geht es hier
um die verschiedenen logische schlüsse
hier werden jetzt noch einmal
verschiedene sätze dargelegt die uns an
leibnitz erinnern wir werden als er hier
drei grundsätze als allgemeine bloß
formale ökologische kriterien der
wahrheit aufstellen können diese sind
der satz des widerspruchs und der
identität durch welche die innere
möglichkeit eines erkenntnisses für
problematische urteil bestimmtes deshalb
das zu erreichende grundes auf welchem
die logische möglichkeit unsere
erkenntnis beruht dass sie gegründet sei
als stoff zu historische urteilen als
ich habe es noch mal ganz deutlich der
satz des touran im grunde hat es nichts
mit qualität zu tun sondern mit logische
folgerung beziehungen und drittens der
satz ausgeschlossen dritten worauf sich
die logische notwendigkeit eines
erkenntnisses gründet das notwendig so
und nicht anders beurteilt werden müsse
das ist dass das gegenteil falsch sei
also kann bestimmt jetzt hier allein nur
die logische formal ist uns interessiert
jetzt aber letztendlich was hier die
material wahrheit ist
und dem nähern wir uns jetzt an an wenn
wir weiter lesen als ich erst mal weiter
jetzt geht's nämlich um den irrtum
ich weiß nicht haben sie den text von
berg bertrand russell gelesen den ich
auf die nicht hingewiesen hatte virgin
trasse diesen text finden sie im sap
system kann ich ihn sehr empfehlen wir
das sehr kurz und sehr verständlich wird
universal sagt wir müssen um wahrheit
bestimmen zu können immer auch bestimmen
was fall scheint ist wir können keine
theorie der fall der wahrheit bestimmen
wenn wir nicht damit auch außer überfall
schallt machen können das problem von
wahrheit' theorie ist sie interessieren
sich für die wahrheit und schließen den
fall von falschheit aus und das wasser
und ich finde sie überzeugen das ist
nicht hinreichend weit muss immer auch
in opposition zu falscher definiert wird
genauso übrigens auch scheint mir vor
dem hintergrund meiner anstehenden
tagung wir können das gute nur bestimmen
orale schwinger das böse bestimmten oder
das tugendhafte wenn wir das nicht
geschafft bestimmt ist ein relations'
begriffen wir können das eine nicht ohne
das andere definitorischen erschließen
und so macht das jetzt auch kant kann
sagt jetzt geht es um das den irrtum das
gegenteil von der wahrheit ist die
falschheit welches sofern sie für
wahrheit gehalten wird wird shanghai ist
ein irres urteil der turm sowohl als
weit ist nur im urteil ist also ein
solches weges den schein der wahrheit
mit der wahrheit selbst verwechselt die
wahrheit möglich sei das ist leicht
einzusehen da hier der verstand nach
seinen wesentlichen gesetzen handelt
also jetzt ist hier noch mal interessant
wegen war als begriff kann vertritt kann
vertritt keinen und theologischen
bereits begriff sondern allen
proposition ahlen weiß behielt wahrheit
ist nur im urteil es ist ganz
interessant also wir können nicht sagen
dass es falsch ist silber es ist nach
kant also ganz klar ausgeschlossen es
geht hier um proposition aale wahrheiten
also nur sätze oder urteile in dieser
das form können wahr oder falsch seien
er soll weiter wie aber wird schon in
formaler bedeutung des worts das heißt
wie die verstandes widrige form des
denkens möglich sei das ist schwer zu
begreifen so wie es überhaupt nichts
begreifen ist wie irgendeine kraft von
ihren eigenen wesentlichen gesetzen
abweichen solle im verstandes selbst und
dessen wesentlichen gesetzen können wir
also den grund der irrtümer nicht suchen
so wenig als in den schranken des
verstandes den zwar die ursache der
unwissenheit keineswegs aber das wird
uns liegt hätten wir nun keine andere
erkenntnis kraft als den verstand so
würden wir nie ihren allein es liegt
außerdem verstanden doch eine andere
unentbehrlich erkenntnisquellen uns und
jetzt kommts zum materialen dass es die
sinnlichkeit die uns den stoff zum
denken gibt und dabei nach anderen
gesetzen wirkt als der verstand aus der
sinnlichkeit an und für sich selbst
betrachtet kann aber dann auch nicht
entspringen weil die sinne gar nicht
urteilen
das ist spannend also nochmal
zusammengefasst nach kant muss und damit
erkenntnis zustande kommt anschauen und
begriff als anschauung ist die
sinnlichkeit sinnlichkeit es viel
weiteren sinne verstanden als wir heute
sind ich kein verstehen sinnlichkeit es
heute etwas körperlich konnotierte
sinnlichkeit bekanntes einfach all das
was uns durch die sinnesorgane bewusst
wird was uns beeinflusst unsere sese der
sehsinn unser höher sind hoch sind das
ist die sinnlichkeit macht kann das
heißt wenn wir nur
verstandes wesen wären dann würden wir
uns nie irren klar warum das können sie
selbst sagen warum würden uns nach kant
nirgend wenn wir nur verstandes lesen
bär legen sie mal was wäre dann der fall
also das ist geht in die richtige
richtung wenn wir nur verstand hätten
dann ja genau
genau
nicht
als unsere urteile wird könnten sich
vorgeblich auf etwas beziehen könnten
nicht vorgeben sie bezögen sich auf
etwas was dann aber so gar nicht ist ne
also zum beispiel sinnestäuschung oder
so dass ich sage das ist silber und
dabei ist es nur irgendwie ziehen damit
ich so ein urteil fällen kann das häufig
falsch ist muss es etwas außerhalb des
büros verstandes mäßigen geben
sinnlichkeit oder anschauen im freien
das ist richtig ich frage mich nur
gerade selbst könnte nicht ein reines
verstandes wesen ein wesen was im
verstand operiert nicht auch logische
fehler begehen
ich meine es vielleicht einen
unterschied zwischen ökologischen
fehlern irrtum ist ja immer eine aussage
über etwas was außerhalb von uns ist
wenn wir nur im logischen raum sind wie
sie sagen können wir gar nicht die
distanz von subjekt und objekt aufmachen
innerhalb deren überhaupt erst wahrheit
und falschheit im interessanten sinne
möglich ist aber könnten wir nicht wenn
wir nur den verstand den logischen raum
haben kontert aktionen machen sie
nochmal mathematische fehler
rechenfehler wir verlieren wir ja nicht
auf sinnlichkeit
weil also das problem dass ich damit
habe ist das klar wenn wir ein
unendliches verstandes wesen haben dann
klar aber wenn wir endlich erkenntnis
wesel sind so wie wir könnten wir doch
ein rechenfehler machen oder logischen
ab leitungs fehler machen hätten wir
doch auch immer tun
genau aufmerksamkeit
sie haben die noch gemeldet
gleich dazu
ja
auf die welt nicht genau man könnte sich
aber eben auf logische objekte beziehen
wir auf die zahl 5 und in diesem ziehen
könnte ich mich täuschen und jetzt hat
der kommilitone gesagt das könnte eine
fehlende aufmerksamkeit sei dass ich im
logischen raum eben vielleicht doch auch
zu kümmern gelange ich kann ja durchaus
auch im rhein verstand urteile fällen
3 bis 3 7 das wäre reine des verstandes
und als wäre er total im logischen raum
ohne sinnlichkeit könnte ich mich
täuschen spannende frage müssen noch
offen lassen aber wichtig ist jetzt also
der punkt dass hier plötzlich ein neues
moment sage ich jetzt mal nicht ein teil
ein moment hinzu kommt zur erkenntnis
dass kant die sinnlichkeit nennen also
die anschauen
die entstehungs grund alles turms wird
daher einzig und allein dem ohne
vermerkten einflüsse der sinnlichkeit
auf den verstand oder genauer zu reden
auf das urteil gesucht werden müssen
dieser einfluss nämlich macht dass wir
am urteilen floss subjektive gründe für
objektive halten und folglich den bloßen
schein der weit wie der wahrheit selbst
verwechseln und darin besteht eben das
wesen des schönste um des willen als ein
grund anzusehen ist eine panische
erkenntnisse war zu halten was den wird
schon möglich macht ist als der schein
nach welchen im urteil
das bloß subjektive mit dem objektiven
verwechselt wird in die wissen szene
kann man wohl den verstand auch zum
urheber der irrtümer machen so
vernehmlich aus mangel an erforderliche
aufmerksamkeit auf jeden einfluss der
sinnlichkeit sich durch den hieraus
entsprungen scheint verleiten lässt los
subjektive stimmungs grüne des urteils
objektive zu halten oder das was nur
nach gesetzen der sinnlichkeit war ist
fürwahr nacht seinen eigenen gesetzen
gelten zu lassen
ja interessant seine theorie des irrtums
ich glaube es wurde auch noch nie eine
arbeit über kann es theoretisch ums
geschrieben während tolles se thema kann
ich mir diese gelegenheit schon mal
nebenbei sagen also er sagt sinnlichkeit
sind es daten haben eine andere
gesetzlichkeit als unsere vernunft und
verstand
wissen sie wie kann diese gesetzlichkeit
nimmt die gesetzlichkeit der
sinnlichkeit das einfach die natur
gesetzlichkeit er sagt sinnlichkeit das
ist das naturgesetz
das ist das ganz strenge jetzt endlich
naturgesetze sinnlichkeit als
sinnlichkeit ist jedenfalls eine andere
kategorie
finden sie das plausibel diese theorie
der fall scheint die kanti entwickelt
der mangel an erforderliche
aufmerksamkeit
nein
ich finde es auch plausibel
nur habe ich noch ein problem damit dass
man vielleicht doch auch im logischen
raum fehler machen kann als endliches
vernunft wesen ohne dass man durch die
sinnlichkeit abgelenkt wird
ok sie meinen also unendlichkeit denken
zu können bei einem verstandes wesen
musik sinnlichkeit schon ins spiel
bringt durch die raum zeitliche
endlichkeit
okay okay sie würden sagen ein reines
von imz wesen hat gar keine
denkprozesses sondern sowie im
platonischen es nie die ideen erkannt
werden so auf einmal auf einen schlag
okay okay ich verstehe es ja ok
ok hinten ist eine meldung
ja also sie bringen mich darauf im
interessanten punkt ich das meinten sie
vielleicht auch also raum und zeit sind
ja verkannt durchaus der sinnlichkeit
zuzurechnen
auch wenn sie a priori sind sind also
keine anschauungs formans erkannt als
raum ein zeitgewinn der seligkeit nicht
so zu verstehen dass raum und zeit etwas
sinnliches wären aber sie sind die
bedingungen der möglichkeit von
sinnlichkeit
sie gehören also nicht unseren verstand
an raum und zeit als reine anschauungs
form sie sind rein also sie haben das
apriori sind aber nicht verstandes mäßig
sind sind ziemlich kite zuzurechnen und
dann würde daraus sich einen sinn
ergeben dass man sagt wenn wir rechen
fehler machen dann brauchen wir die
sinnlichkeit und ein reines verstandes
wesen oder ein verstandes lesen hat
nichts ähnlichkeit hat also nicht
anschauungs form von raum und zeit kann
dadurch nach kant auch nicht mathematik
machen
das wäre dann praktisch mathematische
irrtümer für verstandes wesen
ausgeschlossen
dann würde es mir ein leuchten in diesem
sinne das war auch ihre ihr punkt so ein
bisschen diese richtung es ist ganz ganz
spannend sie sehen hier kann man sehr
viel noch machen das ist eine
provokative these ich habe mit kann
immer noch ein bisschen meine probleme
weil ich glaube dass eben immer auch aus
der vernunft heraus entstehen und das
sagt er kann selbst wenn er davon
spricht dass es eine dialektik gibt
unseres verstandes ziehen sich an das
was wir vorher hat gesagt hatten dass
der verstand vorgibt aufgrund seiner
eigenen operation weise zu wahrheiten zu
kommen
das gibt der verstand ohne sinnlichkeit
vor
das heißt die vernunft die reine
vernunft die toys nach cannes und bedarf
deswegen eine kritik und die täuschung
scheint mir nicht aufgrund der
sinnlichkeit zu geschehen man könnte
jetzt sagen gut die vernunft täuschen
dass deswegen weil sie in uns raum
zeitlich individuen wesen irgendwie
instanziert ist das wäre dann eine
konflikt von endlichkeit und
unendlichkeit von endlichen erkenntnis
objekt das irgendwie ein
zu allgemein vernunft hat die dadurch
schein produziert spannende frage zu
punkten
genau da wäre gar keine referenz gedacht
referenz möglich ich sehe den punkt auch
ja ich sehe punkt auch als ganz
spannende sache schreiben sie ruhig und
esse gerne über kants theorie des
irrtums überhaupt schauen sie mal bei
anderen themen oder anderen philosophen
die wir noch haben nicht immer nur auf
wahrheit schauen sie mal falschheit oder
sie können zb einfach mal sagen was
würde platon dann auch wenn das nicht
direkt sagt der sachse manchen stellen
über falschheit sagen schreiben sie mal
nicht nur über wahrheit zum mal falsch
ein
das ist wieder so ein punkt den ich auch
folien oder auch in diese zur
ratssitzung am samstag kurz erwähnt
hatte sie müssen sie sollten versuchen
einen text die wir möglichst aus einer
frischen ungewöhnlichen perspektive zu
betrachten
dann antwortet ihnen der text besonders
interessant wahrheit über falsch ein
ich nähere mich der war jetzt theorie
eines bestimmten dinkels über seine
falsch als theorie an und kann dann
anhand der plausibilität dieser fall
schweiz theorie aussagen darüber treffen
ob sie eine wahrheits theorie plausibel
ist oder nicht können sie sich auf
bertrand russell berufen der das als ein
erfordernis aufgestellt hat eine
überzeugende wahrheit' theorie dass eine
überzeugende wahrheit sehr überzeugende
falsch heitz theorie hotel das nur als
neben dem berg wieder sehen sie zu
können sie wirklich interessante fragen
an textstellen mal so ein bisschen gegen
den strich lesen eine theorie dann
antwortet ihnen der text auch plötzlich
ganz interessant und bestimmte teile des
textes werden für sie interessant die
davor keine aufmerksamkeit gefunden habt
ja weil da geht es nur die schuld der
unwissenheit liegt demnach in den
schranken des verstanden dass die schuld
des turms haben wir uns selbst bei zu
müssen noch mal interessante
unterscheidung um gesundheit verso
versus irrtum
die natur hat uns zwar viele
erkenntnisse versagt sie lässt uns aber
so manches in einer unvermeidlichen
unwissenheit aber den irrtum verursacht
sie doch nicht zu diesen verleitet uns
unser eigener hang zu urteilen und zu
entscheiden auch da wo wir wegen unserer
begrenztheit zu urteilen und zu
entscheiden nicht vermögend sind
interessant jetzt geht es hierbei um
einen hang erinnert mich an cantz
theorie des hangs zum bösen kann spricht
auch von einem hang zum bösen spannend
also wir haben jetzt einen hang zu
urteilen aber haben mit diesen hang nur
aufgrund unserer sinnlichkeit oder haben
wir diesen hang schon auf uns aufgrund
unserer individualität haben den hang
als vernunft wesen das sind spannende
fragen die man an kant stellen kann
wir haben keine begrenztheit zu urteilen
ja
hmm
genau ist ja der baum der erkenntnis das
heißt wir wir haben das böse kommt mit
unserer entscheidungsfähigkeit ins spiel
und unsere entscheidungsfähigkeit
erkenntnis des guten und bösen
erkenntnis wenn die erkenntnis haben
haben wir eben auch falschheit haben
auch falsch erkenntnis dass haben wir
bevor wir erkennen können im strengen
sinne nicht würde ich sagen
doch wo sind wir in different erst dann
wenn wir den erkenntnisvermögen haben
können wir auch über falschheit sprechen
würden auch man würde auch nicht bei
tieren arbeiten bin ich mir nicht sicher
tiere können sich auch irren aber tiere
haben insofern sie sich irren auch eine
bestimmte vernunft tätigkeiten und ich
sagen ja ein tier versucht irgendwie
verwechselt etwas tatsache dass ein tier
ein apfel mit einer birne verwechseln
kann und irgendwie sich selbst im
spiegel für ein fremdes tier hält zeigt
dass es schon eine form von nationalität
besitzt also der irrtum lässt
rückschließen auf rationalität ohne
rationalität glaube ich kann man nicht
von irrtum sprechen
entspannte sache der zusammenhang von
vernunft und getourt um in welchen der
menschliche verstand geraten kann ist
aber nur partial und in jedem jedem
irgendwo teile muss immer etwas wahres
liegen das ist das was ich gerade gesagt
habe jetzt endlich ne denn ein totaler
irrtum wäre ein gänzlicher widerstreit
wieder die gesetze des verstandes und
der vernunft wie könnte er als solcher
auf irgendeine weise aus dem verstanden
kommen und soviele doch ein urteil ist
ein produkt des verstandes gehalten
werden in rücksicht auf das wahre und
irrige in unserer erkenntnis
unterscheiden wir ein genaues von einem
rohen erkenntnisse genau ist das
erkenntnis wenn es seinem objekt
angemessen ist oder wenn in ansehung
seines objekts nicht der mindest atom
stattfindet wo ist es wenn ihr zimmer
darin sein können ohne eben der ansicht
absicht hinterlegt ist ja diese
unterscheidung ist jetzt nicht zu
so zentral wichtig ist das was der
vorgesagt ist in jedem irrigen urteile
muss immer etwas wahres lichten totaler
irrtum wäre ein gänzlicher widerstreit
wieder die gesetze des verstandes und
vernunft wie können sie sich das
erklären
wieso kann es einen gänzlichen wieder
einen totalen irrtum nicht geben
genau
genau ich glaube es sogar die bloße
struktur eines urteils sichert wahrheit
beurteilen immer sympathisch ist ich
setze etwas in beziehung
da kommt dann eine gewisse analogie oder
wie auch immer rein allein schon ein
urteil zu formulieren was semantisch
oder so taktisch muss ich sagen es um
taktisch korrekt ist ist schon die
erkenntnis da ist schon was wahres
trainern ein wohlgeformtes urteil hat
schon etwas von erkenntnis an sich
könnte uns sagen ja gerade noch dazu
dann hinten ja genau genau glaube ich
auch ich glaube auch die tatsache dass
wir etwas wie heizwert fähiges
produzieren zeigt dass da schon
irgendwas mit erkenntnis im spiel ist
ganz hinten
ja ich sehe ist genauso als ich sie dann
eine große parallel dazu das kommende
zeit von meinem hintergrund meines
momentan interesse ich sehe dann
ähnlichkeit ne das ist sich nicht so
strikt auseinander reißen lässt sind
aufeinander verwiesen ist das an der
these jedenfalls auch darüber können sie
in se schreiben warum nach kant oder
grundsätzlich ein totaler irrtum nicht
möglich ist warum ist das nicht möglich
sandes se thema dieser unterschied den
brauchen jetzt nicht weiter nachzugehen
zwischen einer zwischen diesen
verschiedenen erkenntnissen in einem
genauen und einem hohen erkenntnisses
brauchen nicht weiter behandeln
hier ist doch wichtig dieser satz hier
beginnt hier um irrtümer zu vermeiden
und unvermeidlich ist wenigstens
absoluter schlechthin kein irrtum ob er
es gleich beziehungsweise sein kann für
die fälle da es selbst auf die gefahr zu
hören unvermeidlich wird ist zu urteilen
also um irrtümer zu vermeiden muss man
die quelle derselben den schein zu
entdecken und zu klären suchen
das haben aber die wenigsten philosophen
getan sie haben nur die irrtümer selbst
zu widerlegen gesucht ohne den schein an
zu geben braucht sie entspringen
diese aufdeckung und auflösung des
scheines ist aber ein weit größeres
verdienst und die wahrheit als die
direkte widerlegung irrtümer selbst
wodurch man die quelle derselben nicht
verstopfen und es nicht verhüten kann
das nicht der nämliche schein wenn man
ihn nicht kennt in anderen fällen
wiederum zimmern verleiht den sind wir
auch überzeugt worden dass wir gehört
haben so bleibt uns doch im falle der
schein selbst der unsere natur zum grund
liegt nicht gehoben ist noch skrupel
übrig so wenig wie auch zu deren
rechtfertigung vorbringen können das
sagte jetzt hier was ist die fehler der
bisherigen philosophie
das hat sie
versäumt
genau den grund des notrufs genau den
grund genau mechanismus des irrtums nur
einzelne wahrheiten als sie hat keine
theorie des irrtums generell das will
kann jetzt hier geben eine logik des
scheins in die philosophie des scheins
das ist spannend durch erklärung des
scheins lästern überdies auch den
irrenden eine art und billigkeit wieder
fahren denn es wird niemand zugeben dass
er ohne irgendein scheint der wahrheit
gehört habe
vielleicht auch einen scharfsinnigen
hätte täuschen können wenn es hierbei
auf subjektive gründe ankommt schon wo
der schein auch dem gemeinen verstanden
dass es kommunen offenbar ist heißt eine
abgeschmackte oder ungereimtheit der
absurdität ist immer ein persönlicher
tadeln vermeiden muss insbesondere bei
widerlegung der firma also zum hat immer
den schein der wahrheit
wir tauschen uns nicht so dass wir
sehenden auges das falsche für das wahre
ausgeben
das heißt in jedem wird um sind wir
eigentlich der wahrheit auf der spur ist
hört auch wieder dazu dass in jedem
eigentlich etwas von wahrheit enthalten
ist ja weil wir eigentlich damit den
schein der wahrheit haben oder zumindest
eine position gebildet haben die
wahrheit' wert fähig ist da ist
erscheint der wahrheit drin in dem eine
position mehrheitsfähig ist haben wir
die wahrheit irgendwo im spiel auch wenn
es nur scheint der fall ist ganz hinten
genau genau völlig richtig der rationale
irrtum wäre praktisch ein irrtum der es
in sehenden auges begangen wird ja
niemand wird sich sehenden auges jemand
vielleicht wollten sie meiner
mathematikarbeit den lehrer der
lehrerinnen eins auswischen und haben
bewusst was falsches hingeschrieben aber
dann war es ja kein irrtum war das ja
praktisch sie haben erkannt dass es
falsch war also dem irrtum des irrtums
willen zu tun dass das scheint gar nicht
möglich zu sagen wir brauchen immer um
von irrtum sprechen zu können den schein
der wahrheit wir brauchen immer das als
ob eine ganz interessante struktur wie
sie sehen das noch vielleicht zum
schluss den demjenigen welcher eine
ungereimtheit behauptet ist selbst doch
der schein der diese offenbar ein
falschheit zum grunde liegt nicht
offenbar musste ihm diesen schein erst
offenbar beharrte auch als dann noch
dabei so ist er freilich abgeschmackt
aber dann ist auch weiter nichts mehr
mit ihm anzufangen
er hat sich dadurch alle weiteren
zurechtweisung und widerlegung ebenso
unfähig als unwürdig gemacht sie kommen
jetzt moralische kriterien spielen wenn
man kann eigentlich keinen beweisen dass
er ungereimtheit wäre alles vernünftig
vergeblich wenn man die ungereimtheit
beweis zu redet man nicht mehr mit den
irrenden sondern mit dem vernünftigen
aber da ist die aufdeckung der
ungereimtheit die du zu alt absurdum
nicht nötig einen abgeschmackten irrtum
kann man auch einen solchen nennen dem
nichts auch nicht einmal der schein zur
entschuldigung dient sowie ein großer
irrtum ein irrtum ist welcher
unwissenheit im gemeinen erkenntnisse
oder verstoß wieder gemeinde
aufmerksamkeit beweist schon im
prinzipien ist größer als in ihrer
anwendung also interessant wie man jetzt
mit leuten umgehen muss die sich irren
ab einem bestimmten punkt können wir sie
moralisch urteilen wenn sie sie kennt
dieses wort beratungsresistenz man kann
niemanden zwingen
man kann immer gegen bessere gründe im
mond sein aber dann ist es plötzlich
eine moralische normative sache jetzt
dass es noch zum schluss vielleicht ein
guter übergang zum ende allgemeine
regeln und bedingungen der vermeidung
des turms überhaupt sind erstens selbst
zu denken
zweitens sich in der stelle eines
anderen zu denken und drittens jederzeit
mit sich selbst einstimmig zu denken die
maxime des selbst denkens kann man auf
die aufgeklärte die maxime sich ein
anderer gesichtspunkt im denken zu
versetzen die erweiterte und die maxime
jederzeit mit sich selbst einstimmig zu
denken die konsequente oder bündig
gedenkorte nennen
das finde ich auch noch sehr sehr
spannend weil es hier zählen hier wird
jetzt subjektivität und inter
subjektivität das ist die frage des
kommilitonen von vorhin kommt nicht auch
seine konsens theoretische dimension ins
spiel ja wohl aber nicht in dem sinn
dass wir hier abstimmen was wahr ist
sondern wir selbst müssen aus unserer
subjektivität und in andere hinein
denken wir bleiben aber dabei immer in
uns und dieses dritte wäre praktisch so
also wir kommen neue kriterien zu sagen
weil wahrheit' kriterien spiel das wäre
eine subjektivität die themen oder ein
authentizität kriterium dass wir das
erste das zweite wäre ein interview
aktivitäts kriterium und das dritte wäre
ein klares kriterium ein einstimmiges
jetzt sich während das zweite auch inter
subjektives kriterium sein könnte dass
dann die konsequente oder bündige denke
das ist doch interessant
hier ist sie wieder diskurs der methode
das hat eine gewisse nähe zur descartes
der ja auch unsere methode an die hand
gegeben hat die hier bekannt ist aber
viel völlig verschieden weil sie wird
sich auch inters objektive beziehungen
mit ins spiel bringt ich denke wir
können es dabei belassen wir sind genau
das ende gekommen
ich denke dass eineinhalb sitzung sind
verkannt gerechtfertigt so dass sie
jetzt in aller frische die nächste
sitzung sich geht
zu gemüte führen dürfen schauen sie sich
die folien an ich habe sie ins lsf
system gestellt wir werden genau in
dieser reihenfolge wie sie hier den live
fragen finden und wie sie es hier in der
folge finden und dann mit hegel
beschäftigen dann wünsche ich ihnen noch
eine schöne woche
bis zur nächsten sitzung